i got to see you just a few days ago
which never happens i never go outside
my house but my wife and i hadn't we
murdered you out i got to go out with
you and your lovely husband mr john
krasinski and we had a lovely time and
then i know you sprung a surprise on me
which i did not know it was my birthday
though yeah we just were having a casual
dinner and john says by the way it's
emily's
birthday and i felt like an idiot i know
you looked a bit embarrassed both you
and liza were like yeah it would have
been nice for a heads up i thought we're
supposed to give you something so i gave
you my watch
that i was wearing
no which i loved yeah thank you um no
you were very nice and you would give me
it was a little tap-ass place yeah it's
very nice and you would give me the last
of every snack on a plate and very nice
and then tell me that you resented me
for it was weird
i have the irish resentment now here
take the last one i hate you forever
uh you know i got to talk to you uh last
time i interviewed you on television we
were talking and you said that you were
not a great driver that's true and you
were sort of blaming this on the fact
that you are from london england i'm
good in england i'm good on the side of
the road that i'm used to right i think
right but what happens when you come
here and you drive around what goes
wrong
it's all shades of wrong um i've
definitely had a few i had one recently
where i was rocketing along sunset
boulevard wondering what this strange
grinding metal against concrete sound
was thinking surely it's nothing to do
with me right and then i pulled into a
hotel in the valet guy was like lady you
got a flat and i was like oh right
that's what it was
wait a minute we don't have flat tires
in england
we have magical tires we do oh i like
that sorry i'm sorry i'm tired i always
turn into dick van dyke no it's very
good it's very i've heard worse you've
heard no you haven't not than what i
just did hello there emily
i'm so sorry
this is why i'm not allowed in your
country
i had someone the other day say to me
would you like some crab cakes i was
like it's crab and i say it like you
yeah
crab crab wait people to say that accent
to you yeah they do it a lot just trying
to try and put you idiots yes
there are people that are that rude and
idiot
yeah incredible
do you find that there are sayings my
mother has old irish sayings that she'll
say every now and then and i'll think
uh she'll say when we were kids if we
were misbehaving she'd say don't be a
bold stump
i don't know what a bold stump is i
don't either i've never heard of that
and i've asked every irish person i've
ever met you know what bold stump is
they've never heard of it really yeah
but my mom's like a pirate or something
but what uh what do you have sayings
that you try out here
we have um
we have a phrase like when someone's
having a bit of a tantrum you say oh he
was really throwing a wobbly
throwing a wobbler wobbly yeah she threw
a real wobbly the other day that's very
strange sounding yeah it doesn't sound
like someone having a fit it sounds like
someone has well i think you know when
kids have a tantrum they're like ah and
there was that sort of feeling
so you say someone's throwing a wobbly
oh she threw a real wobbly yeah okay
and then the other one we had uh that
happened to me the other days i was at a
restaurant and someone said would you
like some more water and i went go on
then
ed's in like go on pull me some and they
got really offended yeah it doesn't
sound right i know it doesn't no
i'll go on then that's what it no it
sounds like we'll go on then
which is i think the way you said it too
right go on then i was at the restaurant
go on there it was that night go on yeah
you humiliated that waiter